qu'est ce qui vous amène sur cette
croisière
mon fiancé m'a planté devant l'hôtel il
ya quelques jours et mon père que je
n'avais pas vu depuis l'âge de 5 ans
s'est pointé à mon mariage sans rien
dire et puis on a passé la soirée à se
saouler tous les deux et j'ai dû avoir
un trou noir parce que bonjour chéri est
gelée traîner sur ce bateau réservé au
départ à ma lune de miel
ouah je ferais pas ça avec mon père
avant son 200ème anniversaire
vous êtes dans la suède jeune mari et
les citations taisez-vous c'est mon père
je te promets que je serai de retour
jeudi d'accord je partirai plutôt parce
que j'ai aucun besoin de vacances
rochelle ici la terre rachel est est-ce
que ça va
[Musique]
je vais bien tu vas continuer à faire
comme si tout allait bien après ce qu'il
s'est passé
il en a rien à faire de ce que tu crois
ya aucune raison que qui que ce soit
continuant à s'inquiéter pour moi même
et je lui en veux même pas en tant que
thérapeute j'ai quand même quatre mois
d'expérience ok alors je vous donne mon
avis là dessus
vous avez tout faux merci beaucoup
ça sort
il était hors de question que je finisse
ma vie tout seul c'est pas anodin
d'avoir peur des vivres au sol
[Musique]
aller loin
était beaucoup mieux sans moi
[Musique]
ap
ah non
pourquoi est ce que tu es là après
toutes ces années pourquoi maintenant
pourquoi
[Musique]
rachel rachel rachel c'est papa après
harry tidiane sy merci dans l'eau on
savait pas c'était cool super